well last year Americans said their top
resolutions including eating healthier
yeah and exercising more sure US News
and World Report says 80% of resolutions
fail by the second week of February some
pretty dismal prospect New York Times
bestselling author James clear says
making your habits stick throughout 2020
is about focusing on your daily routine
his book is atomic habits an easy and
proven way to build good habits and
break bad ones James clear Happy New
Year Happy New Year you say instead of
focusing on our resolutions we should be
asking ourselves one question what is it
so the question people usually ask is
what outcomes do I want to achieve you
know and they end up with things like oh
I'd like to lose 30 pounds or increase
my income or reduce stress but I think
there's one layer deeper and so the
important question to ask yourself is
who is the type of person that could
achieve those outcomes and what you
start to uncover as you start to learn
the identity so for example all right
who's the type of person that can lose
30 pounds well maybe it's the type of
person who doesn't miss workouts or
who's the type of person that could
finish that novel maybe it's the type of
person who writes every day and it I'm
confused or you know no you're right so
you're asking yourself who's that type
of person and then the next step is to
build a habit that reinforces that
identity okay and so instead of focusing
on the outcome does the scale move
whatever you focus on showing up as that
identity each day and the way that I
like to summarize this is that every
action you take is like a vote for the
type of person you want to become and so
no writing one sentence does not finish
the novel but it does cast a vote for
being a writer
yeah and doing one push up does not
transform your body but it does cast a
vote for I'm a healthy person or I don't
miss workouts I know a writer who's
who's whose idea was to say to herself
if you just write one sentence every
morning that's the goal but she said if
you write one you usually write more
sure yeah a lot of the time you know you
break through that barrier and then you
end up feeling like doing doing more
after that
but the key I think there are a couple
elements here but a habit must be
established before it can be improved
right like a lot of the time we focus on
this big
whole thing that we want to achieve but
really you just need to master the art
of showing up and so writing one
sentence or doing one pushup or
meditating for one minute or actually
losing one pound
yeah in the long run it counts for a lot
more than what it seems like because
you're establishing that new identity so
then on the subject of achieving
something how do you measure progress so
one basically what you want are signals
of progress right one of the most
motivating feelings that the human brain
is the feeling of getting feedback and
I'm moving forward and so there are a
variety of ways to do this but the the
rough overview is that you want a form
of measurement a form of feedback that
matches the frequency of the habit so
for example take my dad like he likes to
swim he and my mom so every morning
mm-hmm well when they get out of the
pool their body looks exactly the same
as it did and they got in right there's
no feedback there that this habit was
worth it but my dad has this little
pocket calendar and he takes out he puts
an X on that day and that's a form of
habit tracking so I I put together this
there's a habit journal that has like
this track these trackers in the back
and you just put an X for each day you
do it and in this case the feedback the
signal of progress it matches the
frequency of the habits so rather than
like looking at your body in the mirror
or looking at the weight on the scale
you can track it in a way that matches
the consistency that you need to have
you say your ultimate productivity hack
is saying no I'm really curious about
this one well I mean we're at the
beginning of the year and a lot of
people when they talk about resolutions
talk about what do I want to add to my
life yeah I want to achieve this year we
all was talking about that yeah I want
to try to say no more often and stuff I
don't really want to do I don't know how
practical that is though because sure
you have to do well but I do think it's
a very powerful thing and there are a
variety of questions you can ask
yourself you know like one that I like
is what are the minority of my actions
that deliver the majority of my results
so if I could if you could only work for
one hour each day what would you do and
that actually is quite revealing you
start to realize things that you would
maybe take off the table
another question is like what is the
main goal here is this really essential
you know do I have to be doing this is
there there's one I like this question I
think Tim Ferriss came up with what
would this look like that if this was
easy right like if if it was easy for me
to do this and you start to just by
throwing the question out there you
elicit answers that may provide a more
fruit
effective what happened what if you have
a hard time saying no I mean this is and
for many people this is a reality right
and sometimes you you know like let's
say your boss asks you to do something
and all of a sudden you're asked to do
all these things you don't space for and
so I think sometimes turning it around
and asking them you know I'm very
committed I want to be able to do a
great job here which of these things
would you like me to eliminate or D
prioritize to make this new thing a
priority so basically you have the other
person to say no for the person of
authority figure it out for you know
James thank you very much great the book
is atomic habits it's a good one
you